a cbs news poll for this week's
anniversary of the assault on the
capitol finds that most americans think
something like it will indeed happen
again
more than two-thirds in our poll say the
events of that day are a sign of
increasing political violence in this
country and only 32 percent less than a
third see january 6 as an isolated
incident chris van cleave is on capitol
hill for us chris there's so much in
this poll to be worried about including
the number of of americans who see force
as potentially justified on a range of
political issues good morning to you
good morning tony that cbs news poll
also shows the vast majority of
americans believe democracy is under
threat today and as we get closer to
that january 6th anniversary later this
week the select committee investigating
the attack on the capitol is laying out
some of its new evidence about what
happened that day
people have got to understand the danger
of president trump and the danger that
he posed on that day congresswoman liz
chaney the republican vice chair of the
house select committee investigating the
january 6th attack on face the nation
sunday the committee has first-hand
testimony that
president trump was sitting in the
dining room next to the oval office
watching on television as the capitol
was assaulted as the violence
occurred
we know that that is clearly a supreme
dereliction of duty mississippi democrat
benny thompson chairs the january 6th
committee and says there's evidence
members of congress interacted with some
rioters
some took pictures with people who came
to stop the steel rally allowed them to
come and
associate in their their offices and
other things
during that that whole rally week nearly
a year after the attack a cbs news poll
found 85 percent of democrats call it an
insurrection while 47 percent of
republicans call it patriotism and 56
percent of republicans say participants
were defending freedom
a majority expect violence over losing
in future presidential elections
capitol police chief thomas manger says
threats to lawmakers have accelerated
where does the threat level stand right
now it's exponentially higher than it
was five years ago it remains to be seen
if it just keeps increasing at the level
that it has increased or do we as a
country get to a point where enough
people say enough is enough
president biden and vice president
harris planned to speak here at the
capitol on thursday to mark the one-year
anniversary of january 6th former
president trump is planning a news
conference in mar-a-lago tony
yeah i don't often point to must-read
poll numbers but i think everyone should
go to our website and read the full
write-up on this poll chris thank you
very much for that report